thank you for coming to my talk my name
is a Waltman
and I will talk about recommendations at
repiy so first of all about me well I
started as a data scientist some like
five years ago stuff like that and now
I'm leading data team around 25 people
in Argentina I'm from Argentina and I'm
also one of the organizers of poly beta
Cordova that is the PI data in Argentina
and regarding to the like the like day
to day work I like to bridge the gap
between like product and business people
and technical people because most of the
time there is a big up there like
completely two different languages
almost well about droppy I know if you
have heard about but rap is like a super
up mostly focuses on last mile delivery
online groceries restaurants and FinTech
rap is the first Colombian unicorn and
actually work in most of Latin Latin
America so just a disclaimer I know what
about your like what you're expecting
about like the technical part but it
will be much mostly focusing on how to
put your like machine learning models
into production and how to bridge the
gap between the product and the and the
technical part so the first question I
have is what's the value of like
business value of a machine learning
model and well from my point of view
like the machine learning model by
itself the value of that is like zero
because the value is on the product that
you have built on top of it
for example in our recommendation system
the machine learning model is just a
little part of the of the product but
you have a complete product on top of it
building let's say different use cases
for example if you want to show a
similar product complementary products
or personalized recommendations stuff
like that so the value by itself is on
like on the product not only on the
machine learning model so regarding to
to that I would like to introduce like
the concept of the data product like on
the product management side we have like
a tech technological product that the
difference with a data product that data
intensive product is like the goal of
the of the product by itself could be
not a child achieved if we don't have
the data like we depend on rely on the
data to achieve the goal of the product
another interesting point is like you
cannot judge just by good data product I
mean for example I would like to buy a
recommendation system but I mean you can
you can buy but you will mostly rely on
the data you have to provide it so well
there is another I don't know if you
have here but there is a lot of phrases
like data is the new oil so in some at
some points they have like similarities
like both of them needs to be
transformed into a product for example
before it's valuable but the difference
with the data and oil is like once you
use the oil it's gone but the data is
persistent so you can still using it
over and over
well so continue talking about the data
product there is a challenge like almost
every product have the challenge to fit
to the market that's the main challenge
of every Pro - okay I I'm I'm giving to
a market what the market is requiring
but also on data pearl you also need
like you have another source of
certainty uncertainty that is a data
because a previously to start working on
your product you know exactly how good
is the data to predict for example or to
to help you to achieve your goal
mainly because predictions are not
always correct you don't know exactly
you can't warranty the performance of
the model like in advance and it will
happen that you don't have enough data
or enough signal to to make a good
prediction and also even if the model is
working okay on the training set but
after you put it on production like to
deploy it the performance could bury
like significantly so I I love this this
graph this plot like there is a
misconception on what what on what will
be like the effort allocation on a on a
data product on a data project and the
expectation mostly will be like okay I
will be working on optimizing my machine
learning model my machine learning
algorithm
most of the time I just will some time
working on the finding the KPI is that
key performance indicator stuff like
that but on the reality or like on
real-world cases and at least on my
experience that's not that's
not they're like the the complex part
you will have like many others part of
the of the project that will require you
a lot of effort on time for example
collecting the data will build in the
infrastructure and even the integration
process that all of that will
technically most of the time and
optimizing the machine learning
algorithm will be just a little part of
that so even for the new data scientist
like they are expecting oh I will be
working on modeling and doing some
machine learning cool stuff every day
and all most of the day but that's not
true i I'm sad to say that because there
is a big big problem like how to
integrate how to build infrastructure
how to collect the data for the problem
that you are tracking so another like
concept I would like to mention is like
well we have big data I used to hear
like oh we have a lot of data what we
could do with that like on real cases
like on real world scenarios the problem
is not the size of the order of your
data it's like how you use it and how
much information you could take from it
regarding to that I will not go in so
deep on this but there is like some
concepts regarding to the data quality
you need some completeness some validity
some accuracy integrity consistency like
there are a lot of validations that you
need to to check on your data previously
to start working maybe on that because
if not all most of your work will be
like will have an error or probably when
you are going to production will fail
so as I said I used to work as a console
consultancy also and I used to her like
we need to do something with our data
what we could do this and that that's
not a data science problem it's mostly
data strategy that probably the company
should to define the idea of this is
like okay let's find some valuable
question the data can answer you and
after that we define like what is a
return of the investment on working on
data science project regarding to title
that problem it could happen that your
data I mean your problem could be solved
but a completely and simple software
development tool or some rules or stuff
like that
and you you're not you need to start
working on on a machine learning and
complex algorithm so to still talking
about like some part of the problem
management side there is a concept like
is the minimum value product I know an
MEP you know if how many of you have
here please for some fun well most of
you so well but basically the idea of
this if that is your if you are not if
you are trying to build a car you will
not starting like building one wheel
then the second wheel then the check the
base and then the complete car instead
of that you will try to okay let's build
a skateboard firstly let's validate that
the user need a skateboard and probably
it could happen that it not resolved
also the complete problem but you
validate that your way is like the
correct way after that you can start
working on a scooter on a bicycle and
then a bike and after finish that
a car so like iterating on that you will
you learn a lot and about the the time
to adapt to the customer will be much
faster
and well prolly for the for an MEP you
will not need any conception of AI or
machine learning or stuff like that to
fill the probe smart maybe we will just
rub the rules that's enough so two
question I I love to hub on starting
like an MVP is what is my riskiest
assumption I I'm taking on four four
take the product the lead product and
what is the smallest experiment I can do
to test that assumption so having that
in mind will help you a lot like working
in the same scenario like on the
skateboard the scooter stuff like that
you will be validating that and you will
not lose a lot of work once you go to
prepare to customer and say oh no I I
don't need that's not important for me
another concept for for this is like
time is critical so I currently
recommend to always start simple and
establish a baseline and after you have
a baseline you will start working on all
of the part that I mentioned before like
integrating building the infrastructure
that data collection or all that other
part that will help you a lot to get it
on production early maybe just okay
let's build for example an API that
always return the same value and see
with that how to integrate with the rest
of the architecture of the project or
stuff like that and by the other side
there are a lot of research tasks Rea
regarding to a data science project
and what I recommend to do is like
timeboxing them I know if you need to
research on some specific area okay you
will have one day or one week or
whatever but undone that time box you
will need to have an answer it could be
it could happen that it's not the
optimal answer but will it will help you
to continue iterating if not it could
happen like okay I'm I'm spending two
months researching what is the optimal
solution for this but probably with the
simplest simpler solution I can start
iterating over and over them in the same
line like experimentation as I mentioned
before you need to experiment a lot and
test a lot of hypotheses like the first
part will be like defining your goals
what is like the probe goal and it's
kind of related to a product discovery
phase on the protein management side and
once you have that you can start turning
your ideas to hypothesis to validate
once you define Europe a hypothesis you
can start working on designing your
experiments that will let you validate
or not your hypothesis with that like
framework you will have like prove your
theory or intuition with science and
even if you need to validate on
production you can use some kind of a be
testing or stuff like that to Bali it
but with just a part of the of your
customer of your data whatever but like
as the memory before like start simple
and small and then iterating on that
another concept the is like it's really
important to have the
metrics like the analytics
infrastructure at least on on e-commerce
or any web page almost it's a must for
applying any data science and after that
you have like two kinds of metrics like
you have like online metrics and offline
metrics mostly the online metrics are
related to the key performance indicator
or business metrics like outcomes a
conversion stuff like that you also have
the offline metrics that is more like
related to the modeling metrics like
accuracy precision recall what were like
mentioned it before on the other talks
one of the biggest challenge our data
product is like having correlation on
the business metrics and the offline
metrics like on the modeling metrics
since okay most of the business people
will ask you okay if you improve 5% your
accuracy of your model how how much will
improve the conversion for example and
that's the hardest part so I recommend
you to work like hardly defining that
correlation and once you have that you
can still go in an over and over just an
example I know if we have people from
Netflix here but an example of
recommendations let's say for example
serious like stranger things for the
same series a Netflix show you different
like pictures or images depending on
your customer behavior or what you were
like seeing or watching before and they
also like used to to sort them by some
criteria different series or stuff like
that I know if you hear about
but it's like a famous netflix price
that was like 1 million price for a
championship regarding to a recommender
system netflix like the idea is predict
accurately like mobile customers would
like well there was like a competition
there was a winner and after that the
winner solution will never came to
production due to the engineering cost
of that so what's the message I would
like to give you with that it's like
doing a completely complex model could
be like the state of art in the research
area but what we need go into the
production or into the day-to-day work
it may not happen the same because there
are a lot of different factors that
could could be involved another another
point is like human-in-the-loop or human
behinds the machine learning well there
is a picture in Spanish but basically
Netflix was paying people time for tying
some serious ok this is a comedy series
this is a horror or this is a thriller
whatever and why we used to have like
humans behind or in the loop for the
machine learning because it helped us to
learn much faster and much more accurate
than giving completely the control for
the Machine and also help us to to teach
the the machine with some good base of
of data so you should
don't be care scared of like tying or
stuff like that is like part of the the
world they work like day to day work on
almost every data scientist
well and continue talking about
recommendations there like some concept
that you should like or requirements
that you should like achieve on on the
on your recommendations there is a
concept of relevance that the items you
should you should show should be
relevant for the user you should also
have like some concept of diversity like
so if you show always this similar items
the chances to convert or lower than if
you show completely different items
there is another like is like item
fatigue like if you show always the same
items to the to the user the user will
stop looking on your recommendations and
after that you like you lose the
fidelity of the of your customer well
you also have like the novelty of
freshness like there is a time
dependency what happen if you show us a
recommendation let's say on Netflix if
you show to issue if you recommend a
movie that they customarily watch so it
could be it could happen that watch it
again but most of the time you will not
convert it with that and also there is
another concept that is serendipity like
it's a related mostly to surprising the
customer and like be attractive for them
without requirements you also can have
completely different goals depending on
what kind of recommendation you would
like to show to the user to the customer
the gold could be completely different
you'd like to increase your rabid-ass
ticket size or value you would like to
increase your buy frequency or even you
can
I have the objective to stop clearance
like okay I have this long tail a
product and most of the people are not
seeing them how how you could like show
in more much more and also you could
happen could happen like to promote some
brands or product that you have like
some like yeah okay if you get it this
and maybe the Commission I hire stuff
like that and also it depends if you
want to increase your customer loyalty
if the customer feels like you as a
subsystem or as a site a no scheme a lot
like the loyalty will increase and well
basically like with just a little bit
deeper on the technical part the
recommendations are bust basically a
learn to run problem so there are some
metrics like modeling mint metrics
regarding to learn to rank you have
precision a key recolored key F is like
a mix of precision recall and this G is
like you will since it's like almost
sorting a list it's a problem of sorting
a list what if you show the top one on
the second on the second position and
what if you show it on the third and
stuff like that like it's like even that
idea and also you can have the idea of
cobras or your complete catalog how much
of your items are you showing like as a
recommender and still going on on that
technical part just mentioning where we
build on roughy since we have ton of
data from the analytical
from the analytics part and from also
from transaction and different sources
we try to to train some embeddings like
it's like a vector representation of
each product or each item you have and
based on that depending on what is the
goal of the recommendation we would like
to to show we train with different
sources for example for if we would like
to recommend similar items which we
train the Americans with the content of
it
for example the scrip the title
description nutritional facts stuff like
that and if you would like to to
recommend complementary items probably
what we have to as a source of data for
that is like mostly related to the
context since we have a cart of let's
say 5 10 20 product and on the cart we
saw like every or most of the time the
customer used to buy jam also used to
buy cheese and bread so with that a
notion of context we train that and
using that we cut like use almost any
like tool famous to like worth wag
fasted fast text bird or even combine
multiple of them to make some embeddings
and also you can build like a user
embedding based on the customer behavior
and from that like it's just like
measuring the distances between the
products embeddings and the user
behavior embedding that is like well
it's mentioned here
what about personalization well what we
we deal on regarding to personalization
is like building user embedding basic on
the the customer behavior but since we
we will work in on that we we have get
in front of the coat our problem that
what happened with the
we don't have enough data to build an
embedding so what are we doing that it's
for example clustering that were
mentioning on the previous talk like
okay this user seems to be similar to
old of that like collaborative filtering
it's also a known technique to tackle
that but you also need to like have
real-time predictions you get in front
of beer computational costs and you will
need to work harder on the feature
engineering you will need like a user
feature store to have like on real time
ok show me what is the device of the
customer where which is the city most of
the information that you may have
offline like from previous information
but also you will need to ok what's the
last item the customer built both so
depending on the goal you are tackling
you're achieving you are going to look
in to achieve like you could get or have
like diminishing returns since it
doesn't make sense to get
personalization on every completely
every thing on your on your
recommendations like if you you need to
to measure that ok if we increase the
the accuracy of the model on for each
user how much money we will get it from
date just mention we use air flow as
like our for the data collection as I
mentioned before for ETLs
and also to retrain our models like we
use this this open source project and we
works really good with that well and
another example on recommendations
Amazon I know also we we have people
from
but what I would like to to mention from
here it's like well Amazon report like
3500 of these revenue was generated by
recommendations and enjoined well okay
but that's not a pure science you
require also some UX or like explained
ability we on your recommendation
seasons it as I mentioned before it's a
complete product so if the science works
really good but the user experience is
really bad
you will not convert this aside also one
example I took from another pay data
I've been before it's like how the UX
matter matters on the recommendations
for example here on booking if you the
if you show like ok 89 88 percent of
your of the available hotels on the city
you are looking for are a are done that
like create a sense of urgency to the
customer and that will be a better
driver than even if you show the best
the best recommendation for that so me
again mixing data and UX is like the way
to go
not only UX and not only data just an
example about how we work at rappy on
recommendations well we started with
some like different approaches like ok
let's start with random items and let's
see how they convert then we show like
okay let's show top salt or show
training items and with that we start
validating the infrastructure analytics
and metrics we did an a/b testing for
that and for that we have a baseline
after we have all of it done and ready
on production we start working on the
like a cube currency model that is
mostly statistical so we die we we have
like an informed baseline that I know if
you hear out the Pareto law that is like
8020 like 80% of the your problem will
be tackle on 20% of your time and the
rest 20% of your of your problem will be
will need like the rest 80% of your time
so with that probably it's enough and
you'll know you need to get on the
machine learning stuff but if you if you
need the machine learning let's start
with simple malls like in your
regulation or also defining some
hypothesis and experiment and after that
start working on complex models like
offline predictions after that getting
on the deep learning or neural network
and once you have all of these let's
start thinking about personalization and
like I'm working on parallel with the
user experience like defining the UX
flow the UI bills interactions stuff
like that will I am still improving
they're like the user experience will
help you almost the same as improving
the model so just an example like not
going complex on the mall going like
better on the on what are you showing as
a recommender system and I think we are
I know if you have any question
[Applause]
thank you for the talk I do have a
couple of questions the first one when
you're building the models are they user
agnostic essence do you have a priori
information about the user
not the cross purchases but actually
using like personal information when
they sign up or something
no we as I mentioned even with the
personalization like part we don't know
like personal information of the user
but mostly we could have information and
the how do you we have bliss feedback so
I mean the user could like give feedback
to us oh I like this prophet a lot but
mostly of the user don't give us so what
we do is working on what the customer
behavior was like what we what he both
before previous yeah previous all their
stuff like that and yeah basically that
I don't know if I answered your question
don't
ochio
so apologist view I talked about this
earlier other the talk of it's the
beginning but you have any views on so
no AWS personalized and Google has an
equivalent offering where they offer
personalized recommendations of service
and it comes along you know comes along
with some of these built-in features
like implicit and explicit profiles me
here's a profile first so the user
versus like here's somebody from Austin
Texas who's you know it's in this
demographic bucket you know a sense of
like what are some of these somebody's
like personalization service options
that are available out there and how
they compare to things that people have
done in-house not necessarily just that
yeah your company moves across the board
well as I mentioned like in the first
some of the first slide let me find
isolate the product you from my point of
view or at least on my experience I
think that may be cool or big companies
are working hard on getting better data
products but most most of the time you
cannot just buy a data product blasted
personalization system most of you
related because you need your you're
hardly rely on your data and because of
the of that oddly I mean you can share
your data with Google and we'll work on
that and then giving like information to
you but for my point of view isn't at
least right now there are like I prefer
to building house that part of the of
the work
well that's a really good question it
really depends on the kind of product
you're going but let's say like between
one month and three months having
information and knowing okay we are
going we are having some errors with
dice or like iterating and almost every
time learning information about what you
have right now in production because of
that you will improve the next iteration
the time well the other like we used to
have like it's a be testing so we are a
win like different parts of the customer
different models so if a model is
performance it's performance is better
we will give my more part of the
customer so in that model instead of the
other one and also learning why one is
better than at all
any more questions okay thank you thank
you
[Applause]